hey youtubers is charlie thank you
everyone that submitted questions from
my Walking Dead QA everyone had a lot of
great questions most notably the people
with like that the walkers with the w's
carved into them and kind of like some
submit a conversation about what
happened to Tyrese let's just start with
those just because almost everybody had
a comment about one of those two things
so careful for spoilers from the episode
if you haven't seen it yet the wolves
are near comment with the w's carved
into the walkers all the cut up body
parts in the back of that car that's
probably going to be the next group of
villains that we meet I don't know that
it's going to be the saviors from the
comics they did that thing in the
episode where Wiltshire estates from the
comics became Shire wilt estates I've
also heard that they're changing the
name of the Alexandria safe zone it'll
still be the same place from the comics
but it'll have a different name so they
might do the same thing with negan and
the Savior's based on what they said I
don't think that negan is coming anytime
soon but if we go to hilltop next like
if that's like the in-between place
between now in Washington DC then we
have to be really close to saviors for
now let's just think of the Wolves is
something that the show's doing that was
not in the comics and the other big
thing Tyree's getting tdawg so to speak
if you're not familiar with what getting
tdawg means tdawg was a character on the
show he was an african-american Tyrese
came on they promptly killed off t-dog
cut to now Noah comes on and Tyrese is
properly killed there have been
complaints about the relative amount of
african-american actors on the show
demographically speaking the area where
there in like in and around Atlanta
there should be way more
african-american people that have
survived the apocalypse I think the cast
is slowly diversifying like now they
have LGBT characters so I think they're
slowly getting there but yes we have to
say it Tyrese totally got t dogged may
he rest in peace ok so on to questions
here we go Natalie Goulding ass did
anyone else notice the half body outside
vultures state with all the legs in the
upper torso and those bodies that fell
out of the vehicle that hit that Rick
hit during their escape yeah those what
I just mentioned I think that those were
the wolves quote unquote whoever that
group is those will probably people will
meet soon next question Michael asks how
far do you think they were from the last
episode and do you think they purposely
cut the seasons in half so they can make
a huge jump in time well no they don't
purposefully joke it's not like a
chicken and the egg thing they cut the
season
just because that's when AMC sells ads
for like they need that winter break
because no one buys ads during that
break it's a weird advertising thing
there's just like peak buying periods so
that's where all their programming goes
as for the time jump I don't think it's
been that long maybe a couple weeks it
seems like they've only gone a couple
hundred miles like they're in South
Carolina like you look at this sign here
so they on their way to Washington I
think they said they're within a hundred
miles of it next question have con ass I
heard they were giving Alexandria a new
name any word on what they're calling it
now I have no idea what they would
change the name to I always think it's
weird when they change the names of
things that they're doing from the
comics you would think if they're gonna
do a comic book thing they just call it
what it is in the comics I think the
reason that they changed the name of
wiltshire states from the comics to
Shire wilt is just because they change
the storyline so much they were just
using it as a landmark they weren't
doing the story from the comics so that
might tell us a little bit about what's
gonna happen when they get to the
Alexandria safe zone when they get to
Washington DC like they'll have the safe
zone but they're not going to do the
story straight out of the comics next
question Eric asks what new obstacles or
new characters do you think that Rick
and the group will face on their way to
DC I would say the group that carved
those symbols into the walkers they'll
probably beat them I'd like to see
hilltop that would be a lot of fun that
would fit in the timeline so it's just
like another big place that they can go
if they're gonna do stuff from the
comics and they did say the producers
did say they're trying to do more comic
book-based moments next question gravity
gold s is Rick becoming a psychopathic
killer he told Glenn he just wanted to
shoot Don the moment he laid eyes on her
does this mean he's not going to trust
other groups anymore yeah I definitely
don't think he trusts anyone anymore
remember how you made them pull the
suburban into the woods and so they
could walk in it's gonna take a really
big slap in the face for Rick to get his
[ __ ] together like he's gonna get darker
and darker he'll be like this until
something major happens and I think it's
gonna involve whoever the next
antagonist is it might be like a lead-up
person to negan like someone who's not
quite as bad as negan but someone who's
so bad that it shakes Rick out of his
funk you can also argue that once they
do get to Washington DC once they get
into the safe zone and it's much more
fortified much bigger a lot more people
rical chill out just a little bit next
question minecraft girl asks do you
think that the group will meet up with
Morgan along the way to Washington or at
Washington
well the producers that Scott Gimple
said that Morgan's story is going to
take place apart from the group so it
sounds like he won't intersect with them
too like right before the finale or at
Washington what I really like to see is
then tied together the markings on those
Walker's heads in the markings that
Morgan is following it could have been
the wolves that let those markings that
Morgan's following we don't know that
yet next question Ben excess do you
think that they're setting Sasha up to
turn into andrea from the comics that's
basically for people that have her the
comics that's just like a more badass
character I think that she's on a
character arc like that but I don't
think she's gonna do exactly what Andrea
did in the comics it's kind of hard to
tell what she was thinking it tyreese's
funeral there she seems sad but she
wasn't inconsolable she didn't go Beth
levels of crazy even in episode 8 she
seemed like she'd really gotten her [ __ ]
together like she was so mad about
letting the group down that she's like
I'm not going to do this anymore i'm
gonna be hardcore if she's not going to
be Andrea from the comics I guess it'd
be better to think of her as becoming a
lesser version of Carol someone who's
badass but doesn't quite have the level
of demons that carol has next question
Mario asks what was with the intro to
this episode I liked it yet it was all
fancy and didn't fit with the rest of
what the walking dead normally does well
yeah so every once in a while at the
walking dead I mean because this is
start of the new season I think they
wanted to experiment a little bit they
want to get a little artsy fartsy
sometimes when they change the way they
edit things it can be a little confusing
but then you watch it again you kind of
get it you're like ok they're just
jumping forward and backwards in time
it's a fun way to tell a story but if
you're not prepared for it then it can
really take you out of the episode it
can be really distracting so now that
you guys have seen this justjust plan
for more weird visual storytelling a lot
of times that has to do mostly with the
directors that they picked for the
episodes each director has their own
unique style for shooting an episode and
sometimes their planned out that way in
the script phase when they're writing
the episode thank you so much everyone
for so many questions these are always a
ton of fun to do I'm really happy
walking dead is back now that my sundays
are like slowly getting back to normal
it's like we're almost back to our
normal schedule so which actually
reminds me congratulations to this
week's giveaway winner Chloe Elizabeth
you in the amazon gift card just be sure
to message me on my channel so i get
your communication info the next round
of the giveaway will start whenever I
post next week's videos all you have to
do to enter that is be a subscriber and
leave a comment
and I think the problem the YouTube
problem that was going on where
subscription feeds weren't showing you
new videos I think that's almost over so
you should see all the new videos like
you normally would I'm posting a new
episode of Gotham tomorrow morning I
have some special stuff that I can't
talk about i'll be i'll be posting that
tomorrow to hopefully so in case you
guys missed it because of crazy youtube
subscription feeds you can click here
for my walking dead episode 9 video and
click here for the game of thrones
behind-the-scenes special thank you so
much watching so let's all high five
I'll see you guys tomorrow